[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
HALLOWEEN IS OVER.
BUT I SEE SOME OF YOU GUYS ARE
STILL IN YOUR JOURNALIST
COSTUMES.
THOUGHT YOU WOULD LOVE THAT ONE.
IN A MINUTE I'M GOING TO TELL
YOU GUYS A SIX-MINUTE RIDDLE
ABOUT TAXES.
BUT FIRST I'M GOING TO TAKE SOME
QUESTIONS, SO.
YEAH, KEITH --
>> SARAH, YOU CONTINUALLY DENIED
ANY CONNECTION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE INTERFERENCE BY
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
>> WOW, Y'ALL ARE OBSESSED WITH
THIS.
IT'S FRICKING LAME.
>> HOWEVER, SARAH IN LIGHT OF
INDICTMENTS HANDED DOWN THIS
WEEK, WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS HOW
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO STAND HERE
DAY AFTER DAY AND MAINTAIN THERE
IS NO CONNECTION TO THE
PRESIDENT.
♪♪♪
♪ WELL IT'S TIME FOR ME TO
TAKE IT
I'M THE BOSS RIGHT NOW ♪
♪ I'M GOING TO FAKE IT
NOW WILL YOU GO DOWN
BECAUSE THIS IS MY GAME ♪
♪ AND YOU BETTER COME
TO PLAY
UH UH ♪
♪ WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING
WHAT'S WRONG WITH ♪
♪ BEING CONFIDENT
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE.
OKAY?
AND WE BARELY EVEN KNEW THESE
GUYS.
THEY WERE LIKE INTERNS OR
VOLUNTEERS OR CARNIES JUST
MAKING THEIR WAY THROUGH TOWN,
ONE NIGHT ONLY.
>> ARE YOU ACTUALLY COMPARING
THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER TO A CARNIE
PASSING THROUGH TOWN?
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE A HELL
YEAH FROM ME, KEITH.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD SUCK MY --
♪ I USED TO HOLD THE
FREAK BACK,
NOW I'M LETTING GO
I MADE MY OWN CHOICE ♪
♪ BITCH I RUN THIS SHOW
YOU CAN CALL THEM LIES, BUT YOU
CAN'T MAKE ME BEHAVE.
♪
>> SARAH, THIS WEEK JOHN KELLY
SAID THAT THE CIVIL WAR COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED THROUGH
COMPROMISE.
>> LOOK.
HISTORY IS A BOTTLE OF MOMENTS
THAT IS FILLED WITH TIME AND
HORSES AND INVENTION OF THE
TELEPHONE.
OKAY?
BUT IF YOU DON'T LIKE THAT, YOU
HAVE GOT TO TAKE IT UP WITH
FATHER TIME.
ALL RIGHT?
BRUCE.
>> THERE IS NO BRUCE HERE.
SARAH, CAN YOU AT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGE HOW OFFENSIVE THOSE
COMMENTS ARE TO SOME PEOPLE?
>> NO.
>> NO?
>> YEAH, I GOT IT.
>> NO.
♪ YOU SAY THAT I'M A PUPPET
THAT I MUST BE
OUT OF MY MIND ♪
♪ ALL YOU MEDIA CAN STUFF IT
STUFF IT STUFF IT ♪
♪
>> KATIE, COME ON.
GIVE ME A FUN ONE.
>> NO.
OBVIOUSLY, SEXUAL HARASSMENT
HAS BEEN IN THE NEWS.
IS THE OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE
POSITION THAT THE 16 WOMEN THAT
HAVE ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT --
>> WELL, HANG ON NOW.
BECAUSE IT'S RIDDLE TIME, Y'ALL.
THIS IS GOING TO HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND THE NEW TAX PLAN, ALL
RIGHT.
TEN PEOPLE HAVE A BAR TAB OF
$100.
RIGHT -- ♪
♪ WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING ♪
♪
>> BUT THE EIGHTH MAN IS A
POLAK.
OKAY, SO HE'S DUMB AS A BOX OF
ROCKS.
♪ WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING.
>> MILK, MILK, LEMONADE, ROUND
THE BACK, THAT'S WHERE THE FUDGE
IS MADE.
♪ WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING ♪
>> AND YOU END UP AT THE
McNUGGET.
AND THAT'S TAXES.
♪ WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING ♪
♪ CONFIDENT
WOOOOO ♪
♪
>> ARE YOU SINGING THE DEMI
LOVATO SONG?
>> HELL NO.